I think we have something we need to
address okay as of when this episode
comes out tomorrow
big boy it's your 60th birthday
you were obsessed with talking about my
age what do you mean he is obsessed with
talking about Milestone bring it up
what's this got to do with me you
because you have brought it up on the
podcast easily seven times easily seven
times you said well I'm gonna turn 50
but that means Conan's turning 60. I
want to keep this on the down low
comedy's all about being young
and I'm putting it out there that I'm in
my late 40s and you every single time we
get on Micah like well in three more
months someone's going to be 60 and then
it's just a hop skipping a jump to 70.
how are you a big boy wow this is you
left right and Center lately what is
happening
I don't want to die touchy why it's the
grave the grave beckons but it's just a
number man oh yeah it's a number that
you keep bringing up again and again and
again six zero yes you're turning 50 in
May that's right okay yeah yeah and you
just turned 40 and then Adams also
turned 40 recently this is we work in
decades here yeah it's crazy Eduardo how
old are you 5 35 yeah okay well you're
gonna need to age five
get on thinking get on sync okay get in
favor like women that are all in the
same menstrual cycle we need to sync up
so you are now like almost to turn 40.
you're almost turning 40. can I go
backwards no okay
compared it to women being on their same
menstrual site like how do you even know
what that is like I read about it once
in uh glamor magazine okay
it was in a I was reading an article
called seven ways to keep your man happy
oh and that was to uh menstruate with
other women yeah men love it men love it
women sync up yeah that was number six
on the seven ways to keep your man are
you sure you're not 70.
I'm 80. okay
so let's address it yeah I realize I
came down on you a little hard but yeah
I will be honest you've seemed a little
obsessed with my birthday
um I just want to wish you happy
birthday I think it's a milestone
birthday you here's the thing two things
you're saying yeah you're saying it's
just a number and it's a milestone
take a side dude
this one's exciting it's it's a big one
you just want to see me in my grave oh
well that's true
and I want to put you there
well you're doing it hey buddy make one
coming
big six oh buddy
you started like a year ago a year from
now the big six oh buddy boy it's just
interesting that we all turn our decade
oh interesting it is it's a guy like you
would get so old oh God this guy oh this
guy over here this pistol uh yes I uh
I'm fine with it as you can tell yeah
but I do it's something I think about
sometimes which is uh you know I'm uh
I've been such a uh foolish physical
comic in in my life and then I think
um I just want someone to tap me on the
shoulder when they say it's it's looking
sad now you know well now you can do
Pratt Falls but they'll be real well
yeah but but I won't get up afterwards
just you'll hear a shattering sound and
a hip will go rolling into the gutter be
honest no if we had said nothing and
just let your birthday go by
you wouldn't have liked that right I
would have had something to be bitter
about oh so which as Sona will tell you
is the greatest gift that would have
been your yeah a good gift would have
been to forget my birthday and then I
could have hated you for it but I also
get to hate you for bringing it up that
you're 60. yeah okay there you go one
more time 60. exactly can I say
something though you take good care of
yourself I do you are exactly the same
at least to me in terms of your
physicality and the things that you do
from when I first started working for
you that's why I don't think you'd be
upset because you look good you sound
good I've I listen I'm thinking of
having a lot of work done oh
um and I know that uh that's not
necessary for a podcast
what are you gonna get
oh you're
what I want big boobs
huge boobs
and I also want those button what I
would get done is butt implants because
I have no ass you know that you're gonna
go for like a Kardashian body I would
like what do they do how does a butt
implant work what's in there what do
they put in there
from other parts of your body looking
around not in that magazine you read
yeah sudden ways to keep your man happy
no it had very I think it was written by
a maniac because it said like sync up
your menstrual cycle with other women
yeah I think Kardashians are so rich
they just get like butt transplant
someone else's butt is given to them for
Bitcoin they get a Bitcoin put in there
you could donate your butt for his
birthday I need all the butt I can get
too and this guy isn't you know okay so
it says for a BBL which I think is what
you're talking about Brazilian butt lift
correct it's just fat is removed from
the hips lower back thighs abdomen and
or other areas with liposuction ah you
don't have I don't have I don't have but
I don't I I don't think I have a lot of
fat in other areas of my body I think if
I do it's in my head
yeah it'd be really funny if I suddenly
had a really skinny head oh like a
really really skinny head and then a
giant ass and I literally had fat from
my cheeks put into my bottom you know
and my big fat Irish paper mache head
suddenly became really skinny okay but I
had this fat ass I was carting around
your hair is the same size yes the hair
is still a big puff pastry okay they
don't put silicone in the boobs I mean
it says they inject the fat into
specific points in the buttocks how does
it not fall like sag down like saddle
bags sounds like a remote for Conan no I
gotta get it done I will say that I do a
lot of uh sort of mental gymnastics in
my head so
um turning 60 I start to do the math in
my head of wait a minute when was my dad
60 and he's 94 now yeah and uh still
doing well yeah but but you do the math
in your head and go wait a minute that
wasn't that long ago it doesn't feel
that long ago that he was my age but he
seemed older right yeah and then you
start to realize that
um you start to hear things like uh
people that you thought when you were a
kid were really old when they played
that character in a movie were your age
and you think oh my God have you done
seven because Brando played The
Godfather at 47 yes and that was but he
was playing someone who was older yeah
but still well also in like 40 I think
Norm from
from 40 I think Cliff was 40 I think I
think Homer Simpson is supposed to be
around 40. I mean I think they make it
like you're you've given up
what yeah like at that age it's sort of
like all right well I'm just gonna be
like a big fat toe and just sit at the
bar not that I no I don't want to say
that about Norman Cliff but you know
what I mean like they made the character
seem older back then you're gonna
probably live a long time that's a
terrible thing to say oh that's gonna be
here I'm sure you'll survive at least
the day
okay well thank you you know I'm sorry I
jumped down your throat Gorly yeah all
right just try to wish a guy a happy
birthday and which birthday is it
one two three four five six Decades of
human life on this planet Adam are you
right he brings it up a lot get on Mike
Adam
get on Mike I actually think you're both
right I think he I think it is a
milestone and so it is like something to
acknowledge it's a big it's a big
birthday sure
um but you're right that he's brought it
up so many times yeah but I also think
that you are I think that you're you are
sensitive about it though you are saying
I shouldn't be I shouldn't be can we
talk about my original ideas I wanted to
get him a gift and just make this about
giving you a gift and it was that
cardboard aircraft carrier you always
talk about you have as a kid but
whoever's responsible for that just
didn't do it so didn't we look forward
and we couldn't find it yeah something
like that anyway you guys look like you
really tried hard yeah so your choices
were get Conan a joyous gift from his
youth basically give Charles Foster Kane
his Rosebud sled or just grind it into
his ear that he's getting old which one
should we do tell him you were going to
get it yeah and then not get it happy
birthday
someone dropped the ball and I still got
it I'm a podcaster now that's the real
gift yeah the real gift is it's people
listening think I'm a real hipster a
real cool cat
um anyway well thank you thank you and I
am uh sincerely if I can be sincere for
one second just great seriously just
grateful that
to be around so that's nice I really am
so okay no literally I am I'm like
you've done a lot
so hard
no but I am grateful to uh I'm grateful
to have this birthday yeah so here's to
another 60 more oh my God oh my God it's
so painful too old all right well thank
you thank you very much and uh happy
birthday
and I'm sure the gifts are huh I don't
see anything
show notes you could have gotten me
something else we had such a good idea
for a gift oh my God you would have just
yeah
yeah you would have loved it all right
thank you Happy Birthday to me